but emotive journalist Montes kirat says
it's freezing in Detroit there are
always at least 10 centimeters of snow
on the ground when he's here maybe
that's because he always comes in
January for the North American
International Auto Show the industry's
first major fair of the year some
manufacturers don't even wait for the
official opening and start launching
their models the evening before black
Mercedes which presented the tenth
generation of its new high-end midsize
car plenty of electronics make the new
e-class the smartest Mercedes to ever
roll off the assembly line
Daimler board chair MIDI that Setia says
that the convergence of the digital and
automotive worlds is opening
unbelievable possibilities most
strikingly for the driver assist
features that now provide safety levels
very close to Daimler's vision of a
crash free world the Bavarian based
competition is focused more on
adrenaline the 3 liter engine and BMWs
m2 puts out 272 kilowatts of power which
can fertile the kupe to 100 kilometres
an hour and just 4.3 seconds it'll hit
German streets for the first time in
April
we had a record year last year almost
two and a quarter million sales all
around the world from BMW Mini and Rolls
Royce we expect this year to see some
growth but it'll be probably at the the
low end single-digit growth thing you
know the world is slowing in some areas
it's normalized in China Europe is still
recovering so we are gonna see growth
but I don't think you'll be over the
same water we've seen in in recent years
Porsche also said records for sales last
year its standard bearer in the US is
the 911 turbo around 1 in 5 of all 911
sold in North America is a turbo it
comes as a coupe a or convertible with a
choice of engines the facelifted version
of the road racer has grown even faster
and the S model harness is a staggering
427 kilowatts of power
once because Martha says that's no
surprise but something else is despite
the jump in power all of the 911s now
consume far less fuel than their
predecessors but only if you don't hit
the gas too hard VW is still struggling
to win back consumer confidence after
last year's emissions scandal sent the
company into a tailspin the CEO was
passenger cars brand says that it's
priority in 2016 is to solve the
problems its cars have caused and reach
agreements with regulators on how they
have to repair the damage he's
optimistic VW can accomplish that in the
coming weeks and then it'll be about
rebuilding the brand dealers are
sticking with VW he says and the company
has a plant that is doing fantastic work
so he's very optimistic about the future
that optimism is reflected in the car
makers to go on GTE active concept it
offers a sneak preview of the model
slated to be introduced on the US market
in 2017
that's the year Lexus is also planning
to launch a new model back in 2012 the
LC 500 was premiered as a design concept
the lf-lc interest was so great that the
luxury car maker decided to take the 4
seater into volume production Lexus is
bucking the trend with its engine which
isn't a hybrid but a gasoline-powered v8
the LC 500 is the first car ever with a
10 deer automatic transmission
on those them fighting mother says that
Lexus is slick LF FC concept sedan also
provides a glimpse of a driving future
that's powered by hydrogen with its H
Tron quattro concept OD also brought a
fuel cell platform to Detroit here it's
all wrapped up in an SUV that was
already showcased as an electric model
at the IAA in Frankfurt last year
hydrogen has a lot of advantages Marcus
says concepts like these combine the
best of two worlds
there's the emissions free world you'd
get with battery-powered electric cars
but you can also fill them up quickly
just like with gas or diesel cars that's
far more convenient than hanging around
at a charging station for half an hour
but there's the chicken or the egg
problem he says without cars like this
on the road there won't be much
infrastructure and without that why
should car makers build these cars
the North American International Auto
Show isn't just for car makers as montes
but also for suppliers ZF is showing an
airbag that's mounted on the outside of
the vehicle and is intended to provide
even more protection just like this
concept for a rear passenger airbag that
pops out the back of the front seats
modern sensors would deploy the exterior
airbags right before a collision they
would extend the car's crumple space
especially along the sides which would
increase the occupants odds of surviving
Mantha says he's seen that the cars of
the future are growing smarter and
smarter like the Mercedes e-class and
it's car 2x communication system they're
also growing safer not just with better
sensors and autonomous driving but also
because of airbags outside the car as
well as in and the cars of the future
won't just be more fuel-efficient in
many cases they won't need fossil fuel
at all but use energy sources like
hydrogen
that seeks consciousness Asha Canopus
trying out Germany's best-selling Mazda
the cx-5 it's been given a facelift with
almost 19,000 units sold in 2015 it's a
cash cow for the maker among all Mazdas
cars he says it has the highest starting
price the facelift promises to make the
cx-5 even more lucrative says Sascha it
has a new stronger gasoline-powered
engine and new extras that can easily
push the price up to around 40,000 euros
about half the buyers opt for all wheel
drive and some 40% choose the cx-5 s
top-line package
like bubbles the moment Sasha starts off
he notices how much quieter the new
Mazda cx-5 is the engineers did their
bit with sound insulation and the engine
compartment he says and the doors and
windows of better soundproofing
partially did a thicker glass
we tested the smallest gasoline engine
with all-wheel drive
it's 118 kilowatts of power can push the
car from 0 to 100 km/h in 9.2 seconds
Mazda rates consumption at 6.6 liters
per hundred kilometers
Mazda has given the cx-5 a new look as
well with LED head and tail lights
starting with its exclusive line series
adaptive headlights that automatically
reduce glare for oncoming traffic are
also available there's also a whole
range of improved or completely new
driver assist systems among them an
adaptive cruise control and proximity
warning from rear parking sensors the
interior leaves an understated and sober
impression Japanese cars have long been
known for being gray and dreary bland
design has often been the norm but in
the cx-5 it now feels more intentionally
laid back the interior is dominated by
straightforward lines clear forms and
top-notch materials
indefinitely sasha is pleased to find
plenty of room in front and back
even though getting in and out through
these small doors can be a bit awkward
the back seat has a bit more room than
it would seem at first glance he says
thanks to indentations for passengers
knees in the backs of the front seats
even so he would want to sit back there
too long the body design makes for a
relatively high loading sill in the
trunk above Sasha's knees a potential
difficulty for people who don't like to
lift but on the inside the trunk isn't
very deep so taking things like drinks
out shouldn't be much of a problem and
there's a lip so if you're hauling
apples or something that can roll around
they won't fall out on the ground as
soon as the hatch is open even being
known Lara hunter the cargo space holds
503 leaders in all Sasha stresses that
the cx-5 was Mazdas best seller because
it has the potential for it it has
plenty of cargo space and seating for
four people
Mazda's next big hit may well be the
cx-3 it's a little smaller but also a
bit more affordable the cx-3 has been in
showroom since last june as a smaller
SUV alternative to its big brother the
cx-5
a car test Irvine Hogue Dyson Ophir
explains that in an accident children
are seven times more likely to suffer
serious or fatal injuries if they're not
correctly secured the quality of the
safety features is also important and
something parents really need to get
right is the child seat ISOFIX is a
standardized connector that securely
fastens the child's seat to the car it
saves you from getting tangled up trying
to attach the seat using the seat belt
if everything is fitted correctly the
child should suffer minimal impact in an
accident my note says that if your car
doesn't have ISOFIX connectors the child
seat can be attached using the seat
belts just make sure the belt isn't
twisted and you must always deactivate
the passenger airbag by thousands
yeah but the Activia
for many families the stressful part of
going on vacation is loading up the
trunk then adults should make sure
everyone strapped in and ready to go
small children at least babies under 18
months should be in seats facing
backwards this supports the child's head
neck and back and provides excellent
protection and case of a head-on
collision
with older children it's important that
their heads don't stick out too far over
the top of the seat this avoids head and
neck injuries during a rear collision
always use the belt to strap the child
in and read the instructions carefully
site impacts are especially dangerous
explains linehalt but modern side
airbags provide extra protection for
children and seats facing forwards or
backwards but it's important to make
sure no objects like toys or clothes are
left between the side airbag cover and
the child seat in case of a crash these
could go flying and might be very
dangerous no matter what fun the
passengers are having the driver should
never get distracted there should always
be an adult passenger to keep an eye on
the back seats and make sure the
children are safe
temperature is also a key factor keeping
the car at a constant 22 degrees Celsius
keeps your kids from getting cold and
also holds fuel consumption down but to
finish up let's take a look at how not
to do it
the child sitting on an adult's lap or
on the armrest without a seatbelt
standing in front of the passenger seat
lying on the back seats
or even sitting in the trunk
can I'm taking children in the car is a
big responsibility but just a few simple
steps can keep your little ones safe on
the road
it's on Droid Simmons first encounter
with a car that's popular among people
who spend lots of time on the road the
Ford Mondeo okay our car tester isn't
normally a fan of Ford interiors but he
thinks this one is actually pretty nice
the control elements have been
significantly reduced and they're nicely
arranged it doesn't take Andre long to
find his way around he also points out
the semi digital display switch provides
lots of information the quality feels
good he says nice soft materials looks
great
his test car has titanium fittings and a
110 kilowatt two-liter diesel engine
it'll set you back almost 40,000 euros
in Germany an equivalent VW Passat which
is the top dog in the sector costs
around 5,000 more that's a considerable
difference in price one that might make
you reconsider plumping for the market
leader
Andre makes a pit stop at a beverage
shop and passing the mondale looks like
it could provide a fair amount of
storage although it does fall about 100
litres short of the Passat but facts and
figures don't really say that much what
does that mean for everyday activities
on device got 10 crates of water he's
going to see how many he can fit inside
the Mondeo the trunks had a good loading
height especially for heavy objects
you're back well thank you with the back
seats up
Andres managed to pack in six crates and
he couldn't get in the other four if he
lowered them and most modern station
wagons he says there's a mechanism in
the trunk for that sadly not here but if
you press this button twice the trailer
hitch pops out automatically and most
cars this isn't fully electric whether
it's a sales rep or a parent most
station wagon customers are just looking
for a safe comfortable car does the
Mondeo meet that demand
Andre thinks the mondale suspension is
on the comfortable side but if you take
a curve too sharply you might find it
has a tendency to lean over a little too
far still he doesn't ever feel unsafe or
that the Mondeo is losing its grip on
the road his test car is a standard
automatic gearbox rather than the dual
clutch transmission you'd find in a VW
but don't worry says on toy it changes
gears so quickly that it doesn't affect
driving comfort he's taking them on Dale
for a spin on the Autobahn to test its
mettle over long distances here the cars
comfort really comes to the fore its
powerful engine and fine technical
details are impressive
on the Autobahn Andrei tests out many of
the assist systems like collision assist
it warns him if he's too close to the
car in front he reckons Ford got the
idea from Volvo but it's still pretty
good
another Mondeo highlight the spacious
rear seats as often gondola is impressed
by the amount of space he says he always
feels a lot taller sitting than standing
and here P has ample space back it's
really comfortable but more important
than that is the seat belt it's thicker
than a normal belt and the buckle
doesn't let you pull it up and down that
makes it a bit clumsy he says but
there's a good reason for it the seat
belt air bag on delay explains that in
case of an accident a gas cartridge
inflates this section which helps
prevent your ribs from breaking and at
300 euros it's a good investment because
who normally sits in the back the kids
that's an important selling point
compared to the Passat which at least
nominally comes out on top but you can't
measure design and he thinks the chrome
grille really outshines the plain old VW
designs from a Saab in getting that from
a Levesque design awesome pave concern
pascale cop lives for classic sports
cars mostly British designs in
engineering are important to pasta
shapes tell you instantly whether you're
looking at a Jaguar XK coupe a or C type
there's something about the designs that
can't be reproduced modern car makers
can't touch them there are some nice
ideas in modern cars he says but a lot
of great things were around back then
that you don't see anymore like the mg c
GT Sebring most of the fewer than 5,000
Sebring's were made in 1968 hardly any
have survived they were popular as
racing and rally cars and plenty ended
up as a pile of twisted metal pascal
runs an event agency he loves tooling
around country roads in his Sebring
Pascal says the classic racers sound
look and handling are all missing in
modern cars hearing the Webber
carburetor moan as it sucks in air when
you open it up gives him much more of a
thrill than any modern fuel injection
system ever could the mg in the name is
the car maker while the C stands for the
six-cylinder engine GT indicates the
closed roadster body style the Sebring
which is named after a racetrack in
Florida was the racing version it has
broader fenders and a 200 horsepower
engine
Pascal explains that at the time
mg Motorsports relatively small engine
Department built the Sebring for the
Sebring races but as far as he knows
none of the original cars have survived
to the present day
they had aluminum engine blocks of which
none are left
of course he says they were fitted with
Weber carburetors and the cars had an
adjustable chassis they were more than
well-equipped when it came to the engine
it's good what is it
the C brings top speed of some 220 km/h
was impressive for 1968 under the hood
is a real whopper of an engine a 3 liter
single casts 6 cylinder block the
standard version delivered 145
horsepower the modified version some 200
horsepower Pascal had is mg overhauled
by a specialist in England six years ago
and he's been improving it here and
there ever since
he says that unlike most British cars of
the era it's dependable
Pascal's car would have been perfectly
equipped for rally racing that includes
a trip master odometer and a passenger
side reading lamp
and the bucket seats and racing
seatbelts provide perfect support Pascal
regularly takes part in classic car
rallies and for several years now he
would organize his own
like a movie location scout he's always
on the lookout for unusual routes
rustling up the permits setting the
routes and planning the stages are all
part of the job
the right course has to fulfill a number
of criteria the landscape should be
scenic the traffic minimal and
conditions not overly tough on the
automotive Antiques past all points out
that the rally's aren't really about
winning but a certain degree of ambition
doesn't hurt it's mostly about having
fun II says enjoying yourself and
carrying on the tradition first and
foremost it's about having fun and
Pascal cop has fun especially when he's
out and about and one of his darlings
hunting for beautiful roots for his next
rally